[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes le mardi 5
décembre bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal
sur tv 78 tout de suite les titres de
cette édition venir en aide aux migrants
et leur proposer un moment convivial
c'est l'objectif de la fête de la
fraternité la quatrième édition se
tenait aujourd'hui à versailles
à l'initiative d'un collectif
distribution de vêtements repas danses
et chants au programme nous étions sur
place
elle permet de se libérer de ses peurs
grâce à l'acupuncture le ft c'est la
technique de libération émotionnelle une
méthode présentée dans deux ouvrages
publiés cette année par valérie brownie
art thérapeute de voisins-le-bretonneux
elle est l'invitée de ce journal et puis
comme chaque mardi le portrait de la
semaine consacrée à une personnalité du
département à soixante dix ans il
s'apprête à faire le tour de cuba à des
lots alain crampons part pour deux mois
d'aventuré sur l'île des caraïbes
et cet habitant de bois d'arcy n'en est
pas à son coup d'essai pour débuter ce
journal ils sont entendus par la police
des polices six gardiens de la paix des
yvelines sont en garde à vue depuis hier
matin dans les locaux de l'igpn
interrogé pour une affaire de
blanchiment et de recel et les agents
sont soupçonnés d'escroquerie à la taxe
fiscale dans le cadre d'un trafic de
voitures est lésé enquêteurs de l'igpn
cherche à savoir si ces policiers ont
pris part à ce trafic une journée
solidaire pour l'immigrant à versailles
je vous le disais dans les titres à la
quatrième fête de la fraternité se
tenait aujourd'hui au centre 8
organisée par le collectif migrants plus
de 80 personnes ont pu bénéficier ce
midi de vêtements chauds pour l'hiver et
d'un repas festif
comme vous le voyez sur ces images de
camille lambert un événement qui se
tient régulièrement depuis mars 2016 et
l'arrivée de me
à versailles 120 sont aujourd'hui
hébergés au centre des mortemets écouter
le programme des festivités à notre
micro les bénévoles témoigne également
de la difficulté à faire évoluer la
cause des migrants une après midi
d'animations avec des chants ils vont
danser il y aura des danses afghane et
puis donc des jeux qui seront organisées
donc toute la soirée
beaucoup de porc beaucoup de timidité un
malaise aussi on sent un peu coupable
coupable de pas bien faire coupable de
pas faire tout ce qu'il faut et puis il
ya le rejet quand même hein il ya ceux
qui ne nous ne veulent pas d'étranger
ici ça il faut pas qu'on passe à cacher
d'autres actions sont organisées par le
collectif migrants à versailles une
équipe de football a par exemple été
constituée et un petit déjeuner est
servi
tous les lundis dans les files
d'attentes de la préfecture et ce sera
également qu'à bientôt tous les jeudis
d'après un sondage ifop près de 17
millions de français pratiquent le
jardinage et pas forcément sur leur
propre parcelle partager son au jardin
c'est une nouvelle tendance
un acte qui peut être aussi solidaire
comme à versailles
l'association des colibris proposera un
jardin à partager avec l'ehpad val
bièvre c'est un jardin les résidents
vont pouvoir ainsi sur ce jardin bêcher
planté et creusé avec était passionné et
en ces périodes de fêtes cette action
est largement apprécié par les personnes
âgées
nicolas landry et les arrêts ch bavarder
rigoler et surtout partager en jardinant
c'est désormais possible
à l'ehpad leval bièvre l'institut
accueille depuis septembre dernier un
jardin partagé
le concept original permet de créer du
lien
l'idée est simple en fait on s'est dit
que on allait mettre à disposition une
partie de notre terrain pour des
personnes qui ne nous connaissaient pas
en se disant qu'on attendait rien en
retour et puis le pari c'est de se dire
que nécessairement ils vont nous
apporter quelque chose et ils vont
apporter quelque chose aux résidents et
aux personnes âgées dans l'établissement
le jardin partagé est proposée par
l'association les colibris avec en ligne
de mire une société écologique et
humaine
en ce sens elle espère accompagner les
résidants et là en fait c'est quelque
chose qu'on a tous découvert après coup
le lien social avec les personnes âgées
dépendantes et ça c'était quelque chose
qui a pris une grosse grosse ampleur
pour nous c'est à dire que maintenant on
essaie de mettre en place des choses qui
permettent aux personnes aux résidents
de l'ehpad devenir jardiner avec nous
des rires et des blagues les résidents
de l'ehpad satisfait par l'initiative
ont ainsi l'occasion de révéler leurs
talents de jardinier
geraghty cg lycée à une partie et
publiant j'ai participé à une petite
plantation
ça donne des possibilités aux résidents
aussi de regarder devoir de
de s'exprimer quoi aussi la
collaboration de l'ehpad et des colibris
et positive de prochain projet d'atelier
promettent de voir le jour au début de
l'année 2018
on vous en parlait hier dont le 7-8
journal coignard organisé ce week-end
son marché de noël vous vous direz
normal en cette période mais c'était une
première pour la ville saint-quentinoise
bonsoir dominique catelin bas soit vous
êtes première maire-adjointe de
coignières beaucoup de délégations vous
êtes en charge des seniors du social de
la santé du ccs du logement de la petite
enfance des ressources humaines et de la
communication j'ai fini ma liste des
jeux précédemment vous êtes conseillère
communautaire de saint quentin en
yvelines délégué à la santé alors si on
revient sur ce premier marché de noël
c'était donc samedi à coignières quel
bilan peut-on peut-on tirer c'était une
première réussie pourquoi n'y a je pense
c'est une première réussite donc le
marché noël se situer sur le parvis donc
de la mairie un petit endroit bien
sympathique au coeur du village qui
donne directement aussi sur l'église
nous avions je crois à peu près une
vingtaine d'exposants nous avions des
professionnels et des non professionnels
là on a pu découvrir aussi des talents
de créativités de certains coignard ya
que ce soit des valeurs gagnant 2 avec
voilà qui vendait qui faisait déguster
ou gagner rien et aux gens qui venaient
donc son jus de pomme oui pour lui et
malgré tout à fait en amateur les
premiers amateurs tout à fait je pense
qu'on soit violent d'ingres pour lui et
surtout voilà est autrement donc
noël le père noël est arrivé bien sûr
vers les 15h cela tirer qu'un beau
beaucoup beaucoup de monde beaucoup de
je veux dire même des artisans aux six
autres sur lesquels on l'a vu du bois
des choses quand même qu'on s'attend pas
à voir spécialement mais ce que je
pourrais dire quand même c'est vraiment
ce qui est l'artisanat fait pas les
communs de toutes à commun de personnes
qui sont pas habitués et sur lesquels
moi j'ai été un peu surprise de voir ce
que les gens pouvaient faire en
créativité c'est quand même vraiment à
souligner est donc premier marché on l'a
dit organisez première chez noël à
coignières pourquoi il y en avait-il pas
là avant et finalement qu'est ce qui a
rendu possible organisation de ce
premier marché
alors ce qu'a rendue possible j'ai
rencontré une dame qui est venue pour
rencontrer début 2017 qui m'a demandé
pourquoi on ne fait pas de commander rue
mâché noël à coignières j'ai écouté on
n'y a jamais songé
c'est vrai qu'un homme autour de nous il
y en a pas mal et on n'y avait jamais
réfléchi et elle me disait pas ça serait
bien mais ce que je connais quand même
beaucoup de collègues qui font comme
dédé créativité chez d'écouté pourquoi
pas donc on a commencé à réfléchir sur
ce marché noël début de l'année 2010 sec
et au fur et à mesure nous sommes
arrivés à ces vingt exposants et je peux
dire que c'était quand même une réussite
certaine demande donc des habitants on
va passer à la deuxième partie de cet
entretien sur l'actualité plus plus
générale la colère si on reste sur cette
thématique de noël en ce moment il ya eu
un concours de décoration aussi qui a
été proposé aux habitants qui est qui va
démarrer là c'est vrai que mounir est
sûre coignières il ya des rues qui sont
vraiment très très bien décorée au
moment de noël et surtout une rue parce
que c'est vraiment là où les gens
m'aiment viennent par curiosité visiter
ces deux là les du forgeron je crois où
il ya quand même beaucoup de cogner rien
qui décorent vraiment très agréablement
leur mission
qui dit noël fêtes de fin d'année on
parle forcément de la fin d'année qui
approchent à coignières que faut-il
retenir de l'année 2010 est à coignard
et pour un projet qui ont un projet le
plus ça c'est vraiment
local d'urbanisme elle a tout à fait
c'est un point phare alors une
exposition qui était proposé aux canaux
est là qui doit se terminer là qui en
mairie actuellement ça c'est vraiment
quand même quelque chose prêt fin de
cette année autrement
comme tous les ans nous avons toujours
nos activités et nos fais de la scène de
coignières si on était sur le plan
festif dont la fête de coignières qui a
lieu fin juin et qui est aussi un lieu
de rencontre et qui rencontre quand même
je crois en à peu près 1000 e 1000
personnes qui viennent et le final c'est
un feu d'artifice voilà donc ça amène
beaucoup de monde et qu'ils peuvent
retrouver d'ailleurs leur actualité
parent sur un journal vidéo s'était posé
à vienne ce chantier il n'y a pas très
longtemps on a mis en place un poignard
ya cinq six mois peut-être maintenant
donc voila et les comme vous dites si
bien les gens de fonnière peuvent se
retrouver sur par ce biais de vidéos
alors il ya un dernier conseil municipal
qui est aussi au programme tout
prochainement c'est le 19 décembre à
quoi nous risquons parlera déjà de
budget j'ai encore tout à fait dans ce
conseil sur la fin de l'année 2018
dernière question il nous reste moins
d'une minute
est ce qu'il advient des grands projets
établis pour pour l'an prochain à
coignières les grands temps forts a
retenu alors y aura la finalité donc du
plan de local d'urbanisme ça qui va ce
qui va être finalisé là je pense sur
juillet de souvenir de mémoire
bien entendu sur 2018 et ben on va qu'on
travaille sur les projets qui vont être
retenues
actuellement je peux pas encore vous
dire ce qui va se faire parce que le
budget on en discutera bien entendu
entre l'adjoint et le maire qui va nous
donner les directives à mener sur ce
plan là et petit clin d'oeil aussi pour
terminer
oth d'alphonse daudet qui fête ses 20
ans ce taux là et qui c'est comment
dirais-je de théâtre vraiment à une
bonne comment dirais-je fréquentation
merci dominique est loin d'avoir été
avec no mercy et vous première
maire-adjointe de poignard êtes
également conseil communautaire de saint
quentin en yvelines avec une délégation
à la santé pour retrouver toute
l'actualité de quoi bien vous pouvez
vous rendre sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
plongée dans le passé y trouver des noms
d histoire est retracée des parcours les
parcours de nos aïeux mission des
généalogistes passionnés amateurs et
experts se sont donné rendez vous samedi
dernier aux archives départementales de
montigny le bretonneux pour le gêner à
elle les assises nationales de la
généalogie elle présenté les nouveautés
et évolutions de la discipline a lié au
numérique à l'informatisation une
révolution au service de la généalogie
mais qui ne doit pas pour autant
supplanter le travail de recherche
propos recueillis par nicolas d'andré
faut pas que ça soit trop facile la
géologie le vrai plaisir engenio jc de
chercher quand on trouve c'est la
récompense
mais ce qui est important c'est de
chercher est de savoir où chercher
comment chercher
hélas les associations ou un rôle
primordial à jouer notre rôle c'est
d'aider les les chercheurs si on veut on
peut très bien faire la géologie tout
seul dans son coin les deux sur son
ordinateur taper son nom
on n'ira pas très loin on n'ira pas très
loin on va engranger des renseignements
des noms des dates des lieux que des
macchabées ça s'appelle monuments nous
on est là pour
dire aux gens comment rajouter des
feuilles et de la sève alors ça soit
plus un arbre mort les faire revivre ça
parmi eux sont passionnés par les
aquariums ce sont les aquariophiles
collectionneurs de poissons et de
plantes aquatiques se retrouvent
régulièrement pour échanger sur leurs
pratiques et leurs loisirs à guyancourt
le club d'aquariophilie existe depuis 24
ans camille lambert et nicolas d'henri
sont allés à la rencontre de ses membres
quand j'ai débuté l'accord au filet donc
j'ai acheté un poisson qui s'appelle un
bottier la craquante 1 et ce poisson se
fait à 23 ans je lâche t il est encore
là une ou à 27° quelques rochers pour se
cacher et une nourriture riche
pas étonnant que ce poisson se plaisent
ici dans la nature son espérance de vie
est estimée entre 10 et 20 ans quand on
a pour le progrès c'est qu'on arrive à
garder les poissons plus longtemps qu'il
vivrait dans la nature là on en a
rejoint l'objectif principal c'est de
recréer les environnements l'ideo % pour
les poissons qu'on accueille eric est ce
qu'on appelle un aquariophile un
passionné de l'univers aquatique
cela fait 18 ans qu'il a rejoint le club
d'aquariophilie de guyancourt
comme lui ils sont une dizaine à se
retrouver tous les samedis pour partager
leurs connaissances
concrètement il ya de l'entretien déjà
au niveau tout ce qui est filtration les
vitres des aquariums et puis au niveau
de la reproduction bahia certain nombre
qui s'en occupe parce qu'en ce moment on
a beaucoup de poissons des lacs des lacs
d'afrique
par exemple là on en a deux
du lac malawi donc la c1 très grands
lacs africains et on a des pseudos
trophée les bras ça peut être dans
l'amazonie on a différents biotopes
qu'on essaie de reproduire justement
objectifs du club
essayer de rentrer en bourse aux
poissons avec leur propre élevage un
loisir qui se veut avant tout apaisant
ou le bien-être des animaux est le plus
important avant de les introduire dans
leur nouvel environnement en fait il
faut les acclimater
quand on appelle ça voilà une
acclimatation donc ça consiste en fait à
les habituer à l'aube du nouvel aquarium
pour pas qu'ils aient un trop grand choc
par rapport à l'eau il était juste avant
donc chez moi
chacun est invité à rejoindre le club à
condition d'être majeur spécialistes et
débutants pourront s'y sentir comme des
poissons dans l'eau la nouvelle invitée
qui m'a rejoint en plateau valérie
brownie bonsoir bonsoir art thérapeute
basée à voisins le bretonneux vous avez
publié aux éditions leduc cette année
deux ouvrages le dernier c'est celui ci
paru en novembre il y a trois jours
aidés l'enfant précoce à s'épanouir
grâce à le ft donc cet ouvrage loue les
bienfaits de le ft est une technique et
qui permet de se libérer de ses émotions
désagréables ses peurs ses angoisses on
va en parler dans un instant tout
d'abord un mot sur votre profession art
thérapeute ça consiste en quoi
alors en fait c'est pour accompagner les
personnes dans leurs difficultés à
travers l'activité artistique la
créativité mais en lien avec ce livre en
fait c'est
vraiment un peu différent puisque c'est
là je suis thérapeute en psychologie
énergétique et du coup là c'est un
travail entre l'esprit et le corps et au
niveau surtout des émotions alors dans
cet ouvrage vous louez la technique de
le ft pardonnez moi pour l'accent
anglais emotional freedom technique ça
c'est ce que ça veut dire en anglais
donc c'est une technique de libération
émotionnelle traduction en français qui
se fait grâce à l'acupuncture
en fait oui on utilise les mêmes points
méridien qu en acupuncture
sauf qu'au maître des lieux de mettre
des aiguilles on stimule ses points soit
même sur soi en fait et ça permet en
fait de libérer dans le corps le blocage
ressenti en lien avec des problématiques
rencontrées des émotions difficiles à
gérer de manière à libérer le corps
parce que dans le corps c'est là qu'on
ressent les émotions donc c'est une
technique qui allie vraiment le travail
sur sur une problématique et la
libération émotionnelle dans le corps
pour libérer définitivement le problème
se laissait finalement parlé le corps à
la place du mental c'est ça bah oui
parce qu'autrement on a tendance à trop
contrôlé et du coup on a difficilement
des fois du mal à lâcher prise
alors c'est une technique que vous
pratiquez depuis longtemps en fait je
l'aimé je les rencontre est à un moment
de ma vie où justement j'ai trois
enfants précoces et où on traversait des
difficultés tous en famille et où moi
j'étais saturé est épuisée et j'ai
rencontré cette technique justement que
j'ai testé moi-même et c'était une vraie
révélation est du coup j'ai décidé ce
jour-là de devenir thérapeute en ftc
finalement qu'est ce qu'elle apporte de
plus par rapport à d'autres techniques
plus de rap plus traditionnelle oui
alors en fait ce qui est génial c'est
qu'elle est puissante elle est rapide et
que en plus on peut vraiment l'utiliser
de manière autonome donc une fois que
les gens ont apprécié leur coquille ils
peuvent l'utiliser quotidiennement pour
gérer leurs émotions
alors justement vous donner quelques
clés dans cet ouvrage un ouvrage qui
s'adresse plus particulièrement qui
traite la question de l'enfant précoce
et donc il a pour but d'aider un un
maximum d'enfants et de parents
voulaient disent ça vient d'une histoire
personnelle finalement l'envi de et
maintenant se savoir
oui parce que moi j'ai traversé ça et
que le ft a permis à toute la famille de
se rééquilibrer aux enfants de trouver
leur équilibre émotionnel et maintenant
les enfants ils vont bien et il arriva
vraiment quotidiennement gérer ça et du
coup j'avais envie de transmettre
vraiment cette technique qui pour moi
est puissante et facile d'utilisation
car en plus de l'écrit dans ce livre il
ya aussi des vidéos qui sont proposés
des vidéos pratiques et aussi des
témoignages sur le fdj a beaucoup de
témoignages d'adolescents et d'enfants
précoces et aussi des vidéos pour
justement permettre au lecteur de suivre
des séances de manière à eux-mêmes
adaptées aussi leur propre travail 1
alors aider l'enfant précoce est
ouvrages dont il est sorti tout
récemment en novembre et publié
également en août cet ouvrage qui
s'appelle valentin et les points
magiques
un titre un peu qui nous laisse imaginer
sisyphe
c'est une première histoire finalement
pour découvrir le fc une première
histoire se
oui pour couvrir le découvrir le ft mais
surtout si pour apprendre aux enfants à
identifier leurs émotions parce qu'en
fait moi mon travail c'est de permettre
pour moi dès le plus jeune âge
apprendre à l'enfant à des tentes et en
identifier ses émotions pour justement
les réguler et du coup grandir vraiment
en harmonie avec soi-même dans la
gestion de ses émotions qui s'adresse
directement aux enfants la wii ou là
pour le coup c'est plutôt un ouvrage
image et pour les moins de 10 ans alors
dernière chose il nous reste un peu de
temps dans cet entretien dans votre
actualité là vous serez tout
prochainement en dédicace à 50 ans
mylène samedi après midi à partir de 15
heures au furet du nord je fais une
dédicace tout l'après-midi sur ces deux
livres et on en parlait également of
juste avant cette émission vous êtes
déjà sur la préparation d'un autre livre
oui en fait là je suis en train avec un
co auteur avec d'autres personnes
d'écrire un livre sur la santé globale
justement pour amener aussi d'autres
techniques que le ft chien qui
permettent toujours dans le même
objectif d'autonomiser les gens dans la
prise en charge de leur santé
devenir autonome merci beaucoup d'avoir
avec nous les rib rooney merci dans la
russie a retiré peu de vent
un bretonneux je le rappelle ces deux
ouvrages qui sont disponibles aux
éditions leduc donc vous avez aider
l'enfant précoce et valentin et les
points magiques vous retrouver tout ça
sur le site internet votre site internet
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran et donc
c'est ce site c'est ce média point fr
merci d'avoir été avec nous c'est votre
rendez vous hebdomadaire le portrait de
la rédaction ce soir focus sur un papy
pas comme les autres à 70 ans alain
crampons s'apprête à s'envoler pour cuba
cet habitant de bois d'arcy s'est fixé
un défi faire le tour de l'île à vélo
pendant deux mois un voyage qui n'est
pas une première pour lui rencontre
signé michael et demi d'euros je vais
donc partir pour arriver à la havane
ensuite je vais prendre le parti de
remonter ici sur la côte libyenne
dans son bureau alain crampons 70 ans
peaufine les derniers détails pour sa
nouvelle aventure cette arcisien qui a
déjà parcouru à vélo la france le
portugal l'espagne et le canada en dix
ans va prendre l'avion le 8 décembre
prochain
destination cuba cet aventurier dans
l'âme à parcourir en deux mois plus de
2000 kilomètres sur l'île en dormant
chaque soir dans une ville différente
c'est un peu la lenteur parce que je
gêne itinéraire je sais que le matin
quand je me lève je vais le soir me
retrouver à peu près à 70 ou 80 km plus
loin
mais
c'est tout c'est la seule chose qui
m'importe c'est que demain est ailleurs
et puis voilà je me promène le nez au
vent
pendant son périple un crampon emmènera
dans ses bagages un sac de survie de 15
kg avec des vêtements des médicaments et
des outils qu'il installera sur une
remorque
l'ensemble sera tracté à coups de
pédales sur un vélo tout terrain préparé
spécialement pour l'occasion
alors en fait c'est un vtt un très beau
vtt que j'ai eue pour mes 60 ans bien et
que j'ai équipé en grand tourisme
donc j'ai mis des cornes ici pour être
pouvoir pédaler super à l'aise comme sur
une harley davidson
j'ai mis un rétroviseur
parce que ça c'est absolument
indispensable et puis ici c'est pour le
quotidien
éventuellement je peux mettre un fruit
ou une boîte de sardines selon ce que je
trouve en plus d'un vélo étudié pour
paraître toutes les épreuves cet ancien
rugbyman a également pensé à travailler
sa condition physique
sa recette un entraînement dans les
forêts des yvelines deux à trois fois
par semaine pour garder ses jambes de 20
ans mais pour ce grand père cet exploit
n'a rien de sensationnel
de toute façon c'est de la randonnée
c'est de la promenade donc il n'y a pas
d'urgence
si on a un peu mal aux fesses au début
parce que ça peut arriver
ben on fait moins de kilomètres la
moyenne ces 15 km heure de moyenne c'est
que dalle donc 15 km heure pour regarder
la nature
c'est fabuleux et en plus on avance
parce que trois heures le matin et puis
de trois heures l'après-midi ben on a
fait 60 70 km c'est c'est simple c'est
simple comme un coup de
retour prévu en france le 8 février
prochain avec des souvenirs plein la
tête et peut être quelques courbatures
dans les gens khobar hasta luego c'était
une première une journée badminton 100%
féminine organisée au vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines donc une
rencontre samedi l'objectif promouvoir
ce sport le badminton auprès d'un public
débutant le tout par le biais de match
et de fitness afin d'apprendre les
déplacements et nicolas landry est
nickel elle n'est d'euros
clémence brenier 22 euros découvre les
bases du badminton au vélotour national
de saint quentin en yvelines
la débutante s'est inscrite avec une
amie ce samedi de décembre à l'événement
bad au féminin organisé pour la première
fois dans la structure ça avait l'air
d'être un bon moment et une initiation
au collège et c'était un peu forcément
du haut niveau j'avais envie de
découvrir un peu plus ce sport
clémence fait partie des 23 joueurs qui
se sont inscrits pour ce rendez-vous
objectif annoncé de l'événement pousser
les femmes à s'inscrire le badminton
compte plus de 6000 y sont si dans les
yvelines mais reste encore
confidentielle au niveau féminin
le bad féminin représente un quart de ce
chiffre là donc l'idée c'est de vraiment
essayé de donner les femmes à faire du
badminton est un sport accessible à tous
pour rendre l'initiation encore plus
conviviale écoute j'avais organisé un
fit mine tonnes pendant une trentaine de
minutes le but après les déplacements au
rythme de la musique
si en badminton on sait pas se déplacer
on va difficilement pouvoir être intense
où les volants c'est un jeu où on essaye
de mettre en crise d'autant toujours
l'adversaire et du coup pour le mettre
en crise de temps on va essayer de jouer
là où il n'est pas et pour ça il va
falloir se déplacer le plus rapidement
possible et c'est toute une sorte de jeu
d'appui voilà qu'il faut passer par un
apprentissage et du coup c'est en
apprentissage le film in time qui permet
d'être beaucoup plus ludique
après le succès rencontré cette année
une deuxième édition devrait être
organisée l'année prochaine au mois de
décembre
toujours au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines avant de se quitter
et de clôturer ce journal le tirage au
sort a livré son verdict où il
affrontera à concarneau en 32e de finale
de la coupe de france de football club
breton évoluant en nationale 1 soit 5 et
divisions au dessus des yvelinois
considéré comme petit poucet de la
compétition est la rencontre se jouera à
l'extérieur le 6 janvier prochain pour
rappel ou y avait à disposer
des guyanais de l'étoile matoury au tour
précédent c'est la fin de ce set 8
journal merci de l'avoir suivi ripley
reportage a consultés sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
78 bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]